we're creating a fake person let's start
with a biography the more common a name
the better we'll call her Amanda Taylor
our fake girl is a freelance graphic
designer nobody can really check the
organization to find us it's best to use
a virtual machine the free Oracle
virtual box we install a clean copy of
the operating system on it and set the
correct time zone to hide the real IP
address we can use VPN or Tor then we
need to buy a SIM card for cash without
ID verification or use a third-party
provider like
www.onsimcard.com we also use protonmail
or tutunota.com Anonymous email
providers and now the most interesting
part creating an image of our girl we
search this person does not exist.com
and mid journey to make a voice we use
bark and for videos Deep face lab you
think people will believe her watch the
full video